now you might know our next guest as the
stylish and witty mark st james from
ugly buddy and his new movie is so good
single all the way um is sure to put you
all in the holiday mood take a look
what's tomorrow well he's going on a
date
like from grinder no oh my god no like
from mom what well i'm sorry i didn't
want to tell everybody i thought you
ruined it he might not get on the plane
thank you so much okay i think they
should be together yes same
let's discuss that later okay can we
please stop clapping for the
relationship you've decided i'm in with
the person that i have not even met yet
okay you're all gonna jinx
[Applause]
my it michael yeah hey everybody
hello
you look so handsome michael thank you
you look so beautiful merry christmas
merry christmas so nice now i can't wait
to talk about your holiday movie um but
first i want to attack ugly betty okay
because is it true you were supposed to
be in like the pilot and then you had a
thing with vanessa williams tell me what
happened yes well not a thing thing but
yes
that's true
but i was a co-star in the pilot and if
you if you don't know what a co-star is
if you watch if like if you watch law
order
the murder suspect is a guest star
and the person who says he went that
away is a co-star
i was a co-star
and vanessa williams was really great i
played her assistant and i had this idea
that everything she did physically i
would mimic behind her physically okay
what gave you that idea i don't remember
you know it was like he was it was a it
wasn't a lot of yeah
that's it
wow that's exactly it what's the origin
story i think you know
he was a sycophant they described him i
mean literally the only description of
this guy was [ __ ] gay assistant
that's how he was and i was like that's
me
i can do that and and i said this this
is a guy you know he works in a fashion
magazine he's he's the assistant to the
creative director of a giant uh fashion
magazine sort of like an anna wintour
type character he's a professional he's
gotten where he is by being great at
what he does and part of that is
probably making sure his boss is happy
and his way of making sure his boss is
happy is to be like her all the time and
do what she does and so i had this thing
i was doing i was like you know if as
she sat i would sit the same way or
or as she would gasp i would gasp and
she didn't know i was doing it she had
no idea because i was behind her and
someone tattled on me someone took her
aside and said you know what that
queen's doing behind you he is mimicking
everything you do and she said
really
and she walked right over to me and said
i hear you're doing me behind me what
what else can i do that you can do
and she engaged me she said she said
give me ideas and then i'll do that and
you can do it and suddenly we're
collaborating
i'm telling her what if you did that
she's doing that
amazing i love that
and then she reciprocated and because we
had this great chemistry and she
included me and suddenly we were
collaborating by the end of the week
they put me in the cast photo and i was
in every episode i was a series regular
and to me
that shows that tenacity scrappiness and
cleverness wins yeah so good for you now
you're working with another icon
jennifer coolidge oh my god in single
all the way give it to me
give me a fly on the wall moment with
that amazing actress i mean come on look
at that she is
she's everything well she is everything
you want her to be good i love her i
mean she is delightful to be around
she's very funny she'll try something
and then they'll call cut and she'll
just start laughing
now your character on this gets set up
on a blind date
by his mother and your mother and father
met on a blind date my week yes my real
mother and father met on a blind date
they were set up by by friends and we
just celebrated their 50th
[Applause]
anniversary oh come on
and it worked out how did you meet your
partner okay
so my partner and i have been together
for 13 years and we also met on a blind
date that is so crazy
what do you think that's crazy
and we also had a similar like when when
he was first like i saw him at a party
and i was like hey what about that guy
and my friend our mutual friend was like
i'm setting you guys up oh wait a minute
is that a blind date or
technically technically i he was blind
it's like it's like a it's like a
legally blind date right
he i'd seen him he hadn't seen me so
this was around the same time ugly betty
was first starting it hadn't quite been
on the air yet i think and so ryan was
like well let me look this guy up and he
googled me and saw a picture of me in
character on ugly betty looking
completely ridiculous
wearing some
crazy purple get up with insane hair and
he was like what
i'm not going out with this weird clown
and it didn't happen
for two years
i chased this guy and then finally
finally he he he decided to go on a date
with me there are other elements that
i'm leaving out to make myself look
better but
um but basically that's how it happened
okay well i'm in for it now okay single
all the way again a title how is that i
know how i know chad hodge our writer
came up with this title and how has it
not there are a billion literally one
billion christmas movies and they've
never they've never done single all the
way and this is netflix's first gay
holiday film yeah that's right
[Applause]
so
crazy crazy they think about that i
think that the sort of iconic you know
title fits the bill for being a
breakthrough it is it is a it is a
delightful funny very romantic and
extremely sweet movie and i'm so proud
that that this is the movie that uh that
netflix is is first putting out there as
as as a gay holiday romney
[Applause]
well we actually um we found a review of
the movie oh my gosh what already i know
do you want to hear it is it well like
okay
there is a very special film critic um
who actually
wants to tell you what they thought of
it take it away take a look
hey michael yuri congratulations on
single all the way you are starring in a
rom-com and of course
no one does it better than you comedy
heart and bringing the sexy you know you
do i miss you so much i love you so much
our days that ugly betty uh miss them so
but time moves on and you keep moving
with all your progress so
congratulations and
all the best happy holidays
come on
i mean that actually got me choked up
through
she's the greatest she's one of the
greatest people i've ever worked with
and that's really it means a lot to me
thank you for thanks vanessa thank you
for that well thank you for all the good
cheer
funny comedy hearts
and all that you bring to the small and
big screen and all that you do on
broadway just everything that you do
michael you're i am such a fan and thank
you so much for coming on the show and
we can't wait to celebrate single all
the way
which is streaming now on netflix and i
just love you so oh thank you this is
what we need this holiday season
[Music]